ينضم الينا من عمان اللواء فايز الدويري
الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي مرحبا بك
لواء فايز اتهام لاوكرانيا بانها بدات
الهجوم المضاد واوكرانيا تنفي ولكن ما هي
المؤشرات القاطعه التي يمكن الوقوف عندها
لنعرف ان بدا هذا الهجوم ام لا
اولا هناك عده معايير حجم الهجوم
اتجاهات الهجوم
وطبيعه المقاربه العسكريه
الان ما هو حجم الهجوم الذي تم الحديث عنه
من قبل وزير الدفاع تحدث عن 1500 عنصر وعن
150 عربه ما بين عربه قتال مشاه او عربه
قتال مصفحه بمعنى اخر ان حجم القوه هو اقل
من حجم لواء وقد يكون بحجم مجموعتي قتال
بينما التقارير تشير الى ان حجم القوه
التي تم اعدادها لشن الهجوم ترقى الى تسعه
الويم مدرعه
الامكانات التي قدمت ونشرها مركز دراسات
الحرب تحدث عن 500 دبابه عن حوالي الف
مدفع 900 عربه قتال مدرعه وبالتالي لا
يعقل ان يتم شن الهجوم بهذا الحجم من
القوه قياس مع القوه لتم اعدادها عندما
كنا قبل تفجير السد كنا نتوقع ان يكون
الهجوم من خرسون ومن زبروجيا الان الحديث
عن قاطع معين بحجم قوات معينه وسمي هذا
الهجوم
هل بالضروره ان نكون نحن امام مشهد
ينتظر هذا الهجوم المضاد الكبير الذي يعلن
ساعه يعلن وفق ساعه صفر معينه ام ان هذا
الهجوم المضاد يمكن ان يتخذ ربما شكل
عمليات نوعيه تؤدي الى النتيجه التي
تريدها اوكرانيا
الان بعد تفجير السد
اصبح من الملزم من وجهه نظري على القوات
الاوكرانيه
عن اعاده ترتيب اوراقها من حيث
حشد القوه تجميع القوه اعاده تقييم الموقف
الاستراتيجي تحديد الاهداف تحديد اتجاهات
الهجوم لان اتجاه هجوم رئيسي فقدت القدره
على استخدامه لا يمكن لها ان تعيد توضيع
القوه خلال 48 ساعه لهذا السبب انا رايي
التحليل الشخصي الهجوم الرئيسي سواء اتحدث
ام لم يتحدثوا لم يبدا بعد لكن هذه عمليات
تحضيريه من اعاده من اجل اعاده موضع
القوات الرئيسيه
لتتناسب مع الخطه الجديده هنا العمليه انا
اسميها واجزم استطلاع بالقوه لتحديد نقاط
القوه ونقاط الضعف في الجدار الدفاعي
الروسي وبناء عليه
سيتم توضيع القوه الرئيسيه
وتحديد اتجاهات حركتها انطلاقا من حجم
المعلومه التي جمعت هذه الوحدات حتى وان
فشلت هذا على الجانب الاوكراني ولكن ماذا
عن الجانب الروسي كيف برايك استعد لهذا
الهجوم المضاد المحتمل
يعني منذ اشهر حتى يعني في زبروجيا منذ
اشهر في خرسون منذ تقريبا ما يقارب العام
بعد الانسحاب من قرصون بدا القوات الروسيه
باعداد خطوط دفاعيه في منطقه خرسون كان
طول الخط الدفاعي 120 كيلو متر وبثلاثه
خطوط المسافه بين الخط والاخر مع تقريبا
عشرين كيلو متر كذلك قامت ببناء ثلاثه
خطوط دفاعيه في منطقه زبروجيا وخطوط
دفاعيه في منطقه خاركيف الان ماذا استفادت
روسيا من من عمليه السد اصبح لديها وقت
اضافي لاعاده
تقويه المنظومه الدفاعيه سواء من حيث
المنشات الدفاعيه والحواجز والعوائق
والخنادق او من حيث جلب قوات اضافيه تحررت
نتيجه ما جرى من تغريق وعدم قدره الجيش
الاوكراني على المناوره في تلك المنطقه
فالقوات التي كانت مخصصه للعمل على تلك
الواجهه اصبحت الان متحرره ولو بنسبه
كبيره من هذه القوات سيتم نقلها لتعزيز
الدفاعات في زبالوجيا وخاركيف شكرا جزيلا
لك لوقفه الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي
ضيفنا من عمان